there's a chance under that Caitlyn
Jenner is a fan of the show yes I met I
met Caitlyn and she told me that today
that you know that she watched the show
and she is a fan and I have her and what
an interesting world it is you know
here's this victim show that we have in
there's her show and there's this
wonderful revolution that's going on in
the world great any chance that she
might make a cameo on the show something
I don't know but it will she'll always
be in Maura's head but you can come to
craft service anytime and I'll walk her
around and give her finger sandwiches I
don't think so I don't think I don't
think that's how each other no have you
talked to her about the show I mean
other than I know you've had little
brief conversations but i actually had
dinner with her one night with a group
of people and we just talked and chatted
and and she was very very inspirational
to us i mean she said really nice things
about the show it's an interesting world
there are people like my character more
FF Fuhrman is very has a lot of money
and has a lot of power in shops at
Gelson's and then there are a lot of
people in the transgender community who
don't have that power who don't have
that money and don't have the proper
weight yet and everything that so I'm
rooting for everybody